[Music]
joining the premiere of another new and
highly anticipated Star Wars series is a
movie about how playing video games is
good for you a new Teen comedy movie
with a popular Young Star an rt25 fan
pick that will make you reconsider your
high school chemistry teacher and one of
the most influential comic book movies
from 25 years ago it's all coming up on
this week's what to watch
sometimes we have to do what's right
regardless of our personal feelings
buckle up
Pew peeling its way into Disney plus is
the new Star Wars series Ahsoka if
you're looking for a reason to dive into
yet another Star Wars series other than
the fact that Andor was amazing would be
that this show has iconic Origins as in
it technically serves as a continuation
of the Animated Series Star Wars Rebels
which is extra Super Fresh on the Tomato
Meter and where Ahsoka became a
legendary Star Wars character another
reason to watch is that it's also a
spin-off series of the Uber successful
Mandalorian taking place in the same
universe and time frame after the events
of Return of the Jedi it was also
developed by the same two studs John
Favreau and Dave filoni who are behind
the whole Star Wars series Empire and
speaking of the Mandalorian that's where
we first met this live-action version of
Ahsoka Tano played by Rosario Dawson and
if you're still feeling the Animated
Series it's also worth noting that Lars
Mickelson is reprising his role from
Rebels as Grand Admiral thrawn aka the
big Baddie we're also gonna get Hayden
Christensen back as Anakin Skywalker
from the Obi-Wan series and prequel
trilogy and Genevieve O'Reilly as mon
mod from Andor and previous films okay
pretty sure you're sold on this one now
the best Gran Turismo players in the
world
chance to compete in professional racing
dude this is real
into theaters is Gran Turismo this film
is of course based on a game first
released in 1997 for the Sony
PlayStation the series is now eight
games deep spanning five different
PlayStation consoles and has become
their highest selling franchise of all
time with 90 million units sold and
Counting not only is it based on a game
but it's also inspired by a real person
Yan martinborough whose Gran Turismo
skills as a teenager ultimately earned
him a job as a real-life racer with
Nissan how cool is that and thirdly
along with Archie madekwi as the central
character martinborough the film's
strong cast also includes David Harbor
Orlando Bloom Jerry Halliwell and jaimon
hansu a grand cast for Gran Turismo
what's your plan here Jeff is psychotic
and they're picking on the weak and
defenseless so we teach a bunch of girls
how to defend themselves they are
grateful to us adrenaline is Flowing
next thing you know Isabelle and
Brittany are kissing us on the mouse
also looking to take the top spot in
theaters is the teen sex comedy bottoms
you gotta love the premise on this one
about two High School senior girls who
set up a fight club as a way to hook up
with cheerleaders plus it stars AOA
debris who we've quickly grown to love
on the bear alongside Rachel's Senate
who also co-wrote it with director Emma
Seligman in other words a lot of good
young Talent throw in Elizabeth Banks as
a producer and former NFL star Marshawn
Lynch as a supporting character and this
has all the right ingredients
ingredients for what you might ask well
how about a film that has already
certified fresh at 98 on the Tomato
Meter with more than 40 reviews and
Counting and a critics consensus that
calls it an instant High School classic
that feels both current and nostalgic
seriously
I am awake
[Music]
as part of our year-long celebration of
25 years of Rotten Tomatoes our fan vote
picked for the best series of the last
quarter century is Breaking Bad this
show which also won the rt25 critics
poll made its case as one of the best
dramas of all time after five straight
certified fresh seasons and an average
Tomato Meter score of 96 percent critics
couldn't get enough of the suspenseful
storytelling and artsy style of Creator
Vince Gilligan yeah same plus even now
15 years after it debuted on AMC the
premise and lead character are as
Unforgettable as ever as it follows the
UPS downs and many surprises in the life
of a high school chemistry teacher
turned meth Kingpin that is of course
Brian cranston's Walter White AKA
Heisenberg and don't you forget it
thirdly Breaking Bad was so iconic that
it spawned a prequel spin-off series The
critically acclaimed Better Call Saul
along with certified fresh El Camino a
Breaking Bad movie featuring the show's
other big star Aaron Paul we've said
enough time to get some of that good
blue stuff and watch the series talk
about Gatorade folks calm down
vampires
they're everywhere
you're one of them aren't you no
no I'm something else and finally
speaking of rt25 this week marks the
25th anniversary of the Marvel film
Blade the character was created from
Marvel Comics in 1973 as a supporting
character in the comic the tomb of
Dracula fast forward to the late 90s and
Wesley Snipes signed on to this movie
Project after he was unsuccessful in
getting a black panther film into
production gotta love a good backstory
the film was a proven success as it went
on to gross over 131 million worldwide
on a budget of 45 million and that's the
reason why blade has been credited for
setting the stage for further comic book
film adaptations and kick-starting
Marvel's long run of film success woe is
right along with those two great reasons
to revisit this one is the fact that it
was written by David S goyer from The
Dark Knight trilogy Fame it has a strong
audience score despite just barely being
rotten on the Tomato Meter and what
better time to brush up on your blade
trivia since a new version is on the way
from Marvel Studios with mahershala Ali
starring I know I know say less
well there you have it five picks that
will light up your saber be sure to let
us and your fellow viewers know in the
comments what you did check out whether
it was on this list or not remember to
check out rottentomatoes.com for the
latest updates on scores and reviews for
everything mentioned as well as the
movie and TV World At Large and don't
forget to look at our rt25 page for mole
poll results and Nostalgia overload
that's all for today fresh family until
next week stay fresh
[Music]